für die weltbesten ausstechplätzieren
schlagen wir zimmerwarme Butter mit
Zucker Salz und Vanille 3 Minuten lang
hellcremig das zimmerwarme Ei wird kurz
untergerührt mehl und Backpulver zur
Masse gesiebt und alles kurz zu einem
homogenen Teig verknetet in
Frischhaltefolie gewickelt eine Stunde
lang in den Kühlschrank stellen dann mit
den Händen noch mal ganz kurz
geschmeidig kneten den Teig gleichmäßig
ausrollen ich finde 6 mm perfekt auf ein
Backblech platzieren und ganz wichtig
noch mal 10 Minuten in den Kühlschrank
stellen für nur 10 bis 12 Minuten backen
sodass sie am Rand goldbraun und in der
Mitte noch schön sind